this morning our series of dish goes on
a delicious journey to a country at the
crossroads between Europe and Asia I'm
talking about the tiny nation of Georgia
neighbors with Russia neighbors with
turkey population of less than 4 million
people total but it has got a rich
centuries-old tradition of food and wine
Chris livesay visited the country's
capital to meet a chef who has traveled
the world only to realize that what he
really needed was right there back home
[Music]
there's a Land That Time Forgot
[Applause]
but that a prodigal son remembered it is
now on a mission to help others discover
annual screening your phone Georgia oh
this is what it's U.S George no oh it's
country it's small country when you come
you will discover what is Georgia and
how it's small country but how is Big
civilization
much like his country gurram bagdosh
vili is larger than life one part Gordon
Ramsay as the host of a TV cook-off show
shift gaming
and one part Anthony Bourdain exploring
Georgia's far reaches one bite at a time
driven by a passion for food from his
childhood as a boy as a five six year
old yes already at five you were cooking
for yourself the first of all I took the
like some animals in the in the
mountains and I cook so you would hunt
the animals exactly frogs and other
snakes and they said this stuff I cook
and I bring my friends and I give food
and my mother beat me every day that is
a very unique I have to until someday
somebody don't do this anymore
but at 13 the father who taught him to
hunt died turning gurum into a family
Breadwinner and setting him off on a
journey to find a career and himself so
you sold your VCR yeah to buy a ticket
to Moscow exactly so what were you
looking for
I don't know I'm like a river you know
just go with the flow exactly and the
flow took you to Moscow exactly he
eventually sliced and diced his way west
cooking in some of Europe's top
restaurants Spain Portugal France Italy
Belgium Georgian food without coriander
it's not food but after 20 years
mastering International Hot Cuisine he
realized there was one country he'd
overlooked his own
it's Walt
between two volts Asia and Europe
between Europe and Asia Georgia sits
right there for the threshold it sounds
like
Georgia was the original Fusion cuisine
in fact this is what I want to do now
last seven years
I separate to Modern cuisine
in a push my traditional roads up
starting with King Kali now it's time
or to make
grandmother's magic dumplings made from
fresh ground pork beef or lamb hand
rolled then boiled to Perfection you've
seen worse yes
you have salad you have to you have I'm
better at cooking dumplings than making
them I think yeah
next a fresh dip called Kali made from
pumpkin hazelnut pomegranate and garlic
paired with Croquettes coated in corn
flour it's look like Mexican yeah I was
good okay I wanted to say that but I
didn't want you to roll your eyes but it
is sort of Mexican like there's that
Bean
pork combination and it's not like
Mexico is on the border with Georgia
right they nearly cheese that Georgian
quesadilla
hachapuri gurram's version calls for
puff pastry stuffed and covered with
stringy aged cheese
like the one he makes here on his
cooking show
and no Georgian meal would be complete
without wine imagine
we are 8 000 vintage
eight thousand
years the Georgia wine goes back 8 000
years in Georgia
yeah Georgian style orange
Amber wine like this color here if we
make wine 8 000 years how many thousand
years we make Georgian food for good
girls and wine
at least eight thousand years cheers
when you have that much history gurram
says the best thing a chef can do is get
out of the food's way don't change too
much flavors when you eat this
do you feel at home yeah this is my
message for customers
you must feel
your village your grandma always any
food must to be give you in some sweet
memories
for CBS mornings Chris livesay tabilisi
Georgia
that last shot right there what is that
Vlad the kacha kachapori kachapori I
want that I know you can well there is
yeah there's Tama mama and Oda House
downtown but um I love the fact that he
points out that they've been making wine
for 8 000 years and so how do you think
they had to pair the wine with great
Georgian food and great food and that's
how those recipes come to be right it's
thousands of years of experimentation
and Improvement all the way down to his
grandmother who then teaches him and
that's the result we saw it I liked him
too very nice thank you Chris